du groupe de l'Union centriste vous avez
6 minutes chers collègues
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général collègues le groupe
Union centriste d'abord de ce projet de
loi de finance pour 2023 avec le même
esprit que lors des précédents textes
financiers rigueur budgétaire et
recherche du plus faible déficit
possible
avec Monsieur le Ministre le maire nous
sommes à l'Europe avec vous monsieur le
ministre Attal nous voulons éviter le
dérapage budgétaire pour cela nous
proposons une trajectoire différente de
la vôtre en recette et en dépense mes
collègues compléteront mon intervention
je vais pour ma part aborder les
recettes il manque des recettes dans ce
PLF 2023 il manque une contribution
exceptionnelle générale sur les
bénéfices il manque la CVAE monsieur le
ministre pas plus que vous nous n'avons
envie de prélever des impôts pas plus
que vous nous imaginons freiner lalant
de nos fleurons du CAC 40 mais bien au
temps que vous nous anticipons les
milliards de dépenses exceptionnelles
auxquelles l'État devra consentir pour
protéger nos concitoyens et nos
entreprises des crises à venir
à ce jour la maturité de notre dette
d'environ huit années elle est taux
d'emprunt sans cesse décroissant des
décennies antérieures ont rendu le coût
de nos emprunts dérisoires mais c'est
terminé et nous voyons dès 2023 et des
remboursements d'emprunts qui augmentent
et des taux d'intérêt alarmants voilà
qui nous ordonne de réduire le déficit
public nous partageons l'analyse de
Philipp Plein chef économiste de la
Banque centrale européenne qui craint
l'accumulation des déficits de plus en
plus difficiles à financer ainsi que son
effet inflationniste il est donc
favorable à notre taxation et oui
augmenter le déficit alimente davantage
l'inflation que de prélever l'impôt pour
leur distribuer c'est la première raison
pour laquelle nous proposons une
contribution exceptionnelle sur les
bénéfices élargit à tous les secteurs
d'activité
nous avons révisé notre amendement
d'août dernier en relevant le seuil
d'imposition aux entreprises et allant
réalisant plus de 10 millions de
bénéfices net et nous l'avons calé sur
la taxation européenne nous appliquons
le même taux de 33% au bénéfice 2022
supérieur de 20% à la moyenne des 3
meilleurs résultats nets entre 2018 et
la différence c'est que nous souhaitons
une participation de toutes les
entreprises ayant réalisé des profits
exceptionnels pas seulement les
entreprises énergétiques que vous
ponctionnez sans limite à la faveur du
reversement intégral de leur bénéfices
via le bouclier tarifaire 29 milliards
et c'est parfait mais pourquoi les
autres secteurs y échappent pourquoi pas
le transport le luxe les laboratoires
les assurances et les banques celles qui
remontent leur taux d'intérêt monsieur
le ministre le maire en août dernier
lors du premier plaire s'opposé à cette
contribution exceptionnelle préférant
que les entreprises fassent elles-mêmes
des efforts en direction du pouvoir
d'achat des Français en ont elle fait
pour la plupart aucun et pour quelques
autres de Timmy gestes sans comme une
mesure avec les dividendes qu'elles ont
distribuées non elles n'ont pas écouté
Monsieur le Maire alors nous allons
faire ce qui est juste prélevez une
contribution exceptionnelle sur des
profits exceptionnels pour financer des
dépenses exceptionnelles car l’état ne
peut pas toujours dépenser tout seul
pour tout le monde quand ça va bien en
supprimant les impôts et quand ça va mal
en versant des aides il est normal qu'il
récupère un peu quand certains
s'enrichissent beaucoup exactement comme
le dit Monsieur le Maire nous allons
chercher l'argent là où il est pas
seulement chez les gens du numérique ou
de l'énergie partout car c'est juste
comme les baisses d'impôts précédentes
ont su servir tous les secteurs et nous
nous engageons bien à ce que cette
mesure ne soit pas pérenne mais reste
exceptionnelle second point le report de
la suppression de la CVAE jeudi report
mais nombre de mes collègues veulent
suppression et oui le Sénat et les
collectivités tiennent à cet impôts
tiennent à cela ce lien tangible entre
le PCI et l'entreprise entre le nid et
l'oiseau au PLF 2021 lors de la
suppression de 10 milliards de cette
CVAE j'avais proposé un amendement
préférant la suppression de la C3S un
pot taxant bêtement le chiffre
d'affaires même en cas de bénéfice et il
semble qu'il y ait matière à y réfléchir
de nouveau pour l'heure nous estimons ne
pas pouvoir nous permettre de creuser
notre déficit de 4 milliards pour
compenser la suppression de cette année
et d'autant l'an prochain l'État a
besoin d'entreprises fortes et agile
mais il a tout autant besoin de
collectivités fortes et agiles c'est
pourquoi nous souhaitons remettre à plus
tard voir à jamais la suppression de la
CVAE voici donc deux propositions
quelques milliards de recettes
supplémentaires qui ne peuvent que
tenter le ministre des comptes publics
mais peut-être pour nous assez riche je
sais en tout cas que le Sénat le sera
dans ses débats merci merci chers
collègues la parole est à présent à
Madame Esther ben bassin
sénatrice